because I think no I think the lectures
again are engaging and interesting and
most of it is stuff that they don't know
it had never seen before because it's
all stuff I just invented you know or
stuff that other people have just
discovered it is brand-new science but
you know the what they're actually
supposed to take away from it i think is
sometimes daunting what are they
supposed to get out of it they're
supposed to get again the tools of how
you do science so how you estimate
things how you post hypotheses how you
develop proxies to study things that you
can't actually put your fingers on like
you know how hot is a magma we can't
really stick a thermometer in a magma
but there's various tools we have
inferring
it's teaching those kind of steps to the
students which is a little challenging I
don't actually care if they know how hot
magma czar but I want them to understand
that what the concept of a proxy is go
about developing their science tool you
need I think that's it I think it's a
great course